this has got to be one of the wildest
facts I've ever seen start with a 1 kg
block sliding on a frictionless plane if
it hits another 1 kg block assuming
perfectly elastic collisions it
transfers all of its momentum and what
we're going to do is put an immovable
wall to the left that this second block
can bounce off of and for this simple
example there are three total collisions
it gets interesting when we make that
first block bigger say 100 kg in this
case it retains much more of its
momentum with each Collision so it takes
many more bounces before it gets turned
around completely and in total the way
it works out here we end up with 31
collisions if it's even bigger say
10,000 kg and with all of our idealizing
assumptions where no energy is lost and
things like that if you work it out
exactly the total number is 314
collisions as you keep increasing the
mass of that big block by powers of 100
the digits in the number of collisions
will always always match the starting
digits of
pi